das ist Hyundai zu mir empfehlen wir
Scheidungskinder du darfst das ist für
mich so ein persönlicher Film gesehen
kann ich mich mega gefreut dass es in
der Kommentar andere Leute
unter dem Film Teilen ich würde sehr
gerne
zum Beispiel
ein Thema das einem sehr nahe geht
besonders wenn man selbst davon
betroffen ist
alles in allem eine sehr gute Reportage
es spendet einem ein wenig Trost zu
sehen wie viele Kinder auch in der
Schweiz von Trennungen Entscheidungen
betroffen sind und man kein Einzelfall
ist sie ist mir genauso gegangen wie
machen vom Film und ich mit
verschiedenen Protagonistinnen
dann schiebt der Jason LFC ich habe vor
kurzer Zeit als Erwachsene gleiches
erlebt und kann mich insbesondere mit
Mira wahnsinnig gut identifizieren mir
gingen und gehen die gleichen Fragen wie
ihr durch den Kopf insbesondere die
Frage nach dem zuhause fühlen
beschäftigt mich seit Monaten es ist
auch noch ein paar andere UserInnen
Situation nicht unbedingt über den Film
aber einfach wie auch aus dem Grund dass
der Film wird
immer wenn wir wieder drüber
redend am Anfang
aber es gab irgendwie nur so wie der
will sich Blitz einfach Stol und ich
persönlich fand es nicht gut
ich würde gerne ein Kommentar vorlassen
und die meine ich dazu gehören für mich
unverständlich wie erwachsene Menschen
sich so einsteigen können ich würde es
verstehen wenn es kleine Kinder sind in
Eltern sich den Eltern sich trennen aber
ganz bestimmt nicht bei erwachsenen
Menschen
für einige wenn es ihnen
es ist schon nicht so dass ich jeden Tag
so bin wenn
aber ich glaube es ist ja wie auch ist
dass man sieht dass obwohl man erwachsen
ist das gleiche
so und es ist nicht so dass ich danke so
oh mein Gott ich kann nicht weiterleben
[Musik]
überhaupt nicht
es ist einfach so dass es so viel mit
mir gemacht hat ohne dass ich das
erwartet hat so ja also ich habe das
Gefühl dass
dass ich einfach viel andere Sachen
verändert wenn das Bein passiert wenn
man erwachsen ist also bei mir ist
ziemlich versuchen
mit Mami ist schon andere oder plötzlich
mit der älteren über ihre Beziehung das
macht mich eigentlich im Normalfall also
irgendwie ist das jetzt nicht so der
Fall sie und ich glaube das sind schon
wieder erwachsen
von der Beziehung zu
ältere ist schon anders wenn es im
Erwachsenenalter passiert wie wenn du
das Kind bist und mir ist einfach
Kind vor zwei Jahren
und das bleibt so so lang alle lieb
Beteiligten nach oben
genau und auch
jetzt danke ich
bin befinden Frage oder einfach
abgelegen
auf Mini ältere Sex finanziell oder so
einfach dass ich irgendwie finde ich
einfach zack mach mal ähm ja und das ist
ja auch nicht nur spezifisch oder älter
sondern halt wie auch Familie als
konstrukturierendes Stück weit
auseinander bricht und aber Familie fast
geht's ja immer wieder hochzieht
wir nachdenken und so das ist ja
trotzdem alles erwachsen ist und Täter
finde ich manchmal ja natürlich
ich kann die Kinder verstehen aber
irgendwie muss man gesund verdrängen und
akzeptieren das Beziehungen auch der
Eltern in der Regel nicht e sind das
Bezirke nicht für immer haben und hat
Audi für die ältere ist mir wie klar
und ich glaube das ist oft besser ist
wenn man im Bezirk beendet anstatt sich
krampfhaft weiter führen aber für mich
ist glaube mehr der Bruchs in der
Familie wo entstanden ist wo mich halt
belastet und wo mehr
wo mich beschäftigt und zu einer großen
Veränderung
sondern das ganze Familien
wo wir auch wieder hilft dass ich nicht
die ganze Zeit denke und halt irgendwie
auch wieder mache aber ich finde das ist
wichtig das ist erlaubte oft schaffen
und darüber zu reden
als Kind und nun als Mutter würde ich
folgendes mitgeben die Eltern haben sich
voneinander scheiden lassen und nicht
von dir das Kind
das Erwachsenen muss man loslassen
lernen die Eltern aus deren Pflicht
entlassen und Selbstverantwortung
übernehmen für das eigentlich nur schön
der Gedanke dass es ja nicht
älter sind was ich abwendet vom Kind im
besten Fall sondern dass sie einfach
ihre Training vollziehend als Bar
trotzdem hat es natürlich Einfluss auf
Kind aber ich glaube es hat einfach aus
sehr viel mit Akzeptanz von der
Situation und natürlich auch mit
loslassen
verdient aber nicht alle Eltern
verdienen Kinder
das ist mir ja wie ein mega wichtiger
Punkt
mit dem Finger auf älterest zeige und
sage ihr sind schuld dass es uns so
schlecht geht oder dass es ist so Gott
wie sie es gut sondern aber wenn ich
schon erwähnt habe es ist immer Realität
das bezieht
auch für Kind besser wenn sie nicht die
ganze Zeit erleben dass man sich den
trennt aber trotzdem ist es halt einfach
auch für Kind nicht einfach auch wenn
alles super gelaufen ist das sieht man
ja auch im Dominik seine
ältere Hände
vor ihm eigentlich auch nicht groß
gestritten
wo nicht anders ermöglicht
aber Kommentar wo wie gesagt
dass es sich meine Kinder erwartet
wünsche dass ich ältere Ländler Scheide
zum Beispiel der Nordic 82 gibt ich
würde mir eine dog wünschen über Kinder
die sich gewünscht hätten dass die
Eltern sich trennen eine Scheidung ist
ja meist ein Schlusspunkt einer
Situation die von vielen negativen
Situationen geprägt ist nach einer
Scheidung kehren wieder Ruhe Harmonie
und im Falle von neuen Beziehungen der
Eltern Liebe ein ja das war auch mega
spannende Ansatz für den Film wo sicher
Aussehen
eigentlich was besser für meine Eltern
wenn sie sich würde Trennen der Punkt
das entschädigen Schlusspunkt ist und
jetzt nicht ganz so unterschrieben es
geht trotzdem noch viel Situationen und
wo man auch wieder eigene Beziehung
selber merkt hey das hat eigentlich
schon klasse und das ist halt natürlich
nicht einfach so für die Entscheidung
passiert darum habe ich das Kapitel wo
wo fertig europäisch aber mit dem
Verarbeitungsprozess ganz hat immer noch
weiter denn hat etwas Thema hyrote aufs
Parkett braucht und zwar Schritt die
Person heiraten für was ich möchte
wieder Heirat noch Kinder
50% Scheidungsrate Heirat und Scheidung
sind teuer das Keller Geld kann man
andersweitig gebrauchen lieber einmal
mehr in die Ferien fliegen Konkubinat
plus notarischer Vertrag gleich super
Lösung
ja das ist natürlich schon die Frage
lohnt sich überhaupt nutzen
bleibt aber ich glaube eigentlich hätte
gar nicht mal so viel mit der ich jetzt
tun sondern es ist für Kind genau gleich
schlimm wenn sich Eltern
und wenn der Thema Vorschlag kennt
schieben sie mir auch die Kommentare ich
bin immer froh um Inputs aus der
Community und natürlich abonniert doch
der Kanal damit